déjame escribir una matriz de dos por
dos sus elementos serán a b c d en
vídeos previos hemos aprendido cómo
encontrar la inversa de la matriz a la
fórmula que aprendimos nos dice que la
inversa de la matriz a será igual a 1
entre el determinante de la matriz a por
lo que se conoce como la adjunta de
nuestra matriz a la matriz adjunta se
obtiene cambiando de lugar la a y la t y
poniendo el negativo debe hacer esta
formula sirve para matrices de 2 por 2
cuando tenemos una matriz de 3 por 3 es
un poco más complicado pero déjame poner
menos b y menos c
otra forma de pensarlo es que uno entre
el determinante de una matriz de 2 por 2
será de bs y eso multiplicado por la
matriz adjunta de a que sólo es una
palabra elegante para esta matriz solo
es la matriz de menos b menos
todo esto es un repaso si no lo fue para
ti te encargó que lo revise en otras
secciones de khan academy lo que nos
preguntaremos en este vídeo será si
existe una situación en donde la matriz
o sea no invertible pausa el vídeo e
intenta pensar en un escenario o en un
conjunto general de escenarios en donde
la matriz no sea invertida bueno una
forma de pensar en una matriz no
invertible es que de alguna forma no
podamos realizar este cálculo ahora
observa sin importar cuál sea el valor
de a b c yd siempre podemos encontrar la
matriz adjunta pero cuál es la situación
en donde no seamos capaces de calcular 1
entre el determinante y bueno será la
situación en donde el determinante de
nuestra matriz a sea igual a 0 o lo
puede escribir así el determinante de
nuestra matriz am sea igual a 0 en esta
situación observa no podemos obtener 1
el determinante porque obtendríamos algo
indefinido por lo tanto podemos decir
que a es no invertirle si y sólo si voy
a poner una flecha con dos puntas si y
sólo si el determinante de nuestra
matriz es igual a cero porque cuando el
determinante es igual a cero tendríamos
que dividir entre cero cuando buscamos a
la inversa
ahora exploremos un poco cómo se ve esta
situación si nuestro determinante es
cero entonces esta expresión debe de ser
igual a cero eso significa que aporte
menos b por ser es igual a cero o si
sumamos bc de ambos lados obtengo que a
t es igual
abc
y puedo manipular algebraica mente un
poco más esta expresión se divide a
ambos lados entre b y d déjame hacerlo
voy a dividir todo entre vader estás
desde cancelan estas veces se cancelan
entonces obtengo que a / p es igual a c
/ b por lo tanto podemos pensar en la
situación donde la razón entre a y b es
equivalente a la razón entre c y d ahora
bien también podemos pensarlo de otra
manera si anoto mi ecuación original a
de igual abc podemos dividir de ambos
lados entre 6 déjame hacerlo si divido a
ambos lados entre 6 entonces nos
quedaremos con a en 13 es igual ave
entre de entonces la razón entre a y c
es igual a la razón entre b y d
en todas estas situaciones tendrás una
matriz no invertible porque el
determinante será igual a cero
bien veamos algunos ejemplos quiero que
me diga si las siguientes matrices son o
no invertibles tenemos primero la matriz
5 1 3 2
es esta matriz invertible pausa el vídeo
e inténtalo bueno el determinante de
esta matriz será 5 por 2 lo cual es 10
menos tres por uno lo cuales 3 entonces
10 menos 37
como 7 no es igual a 0 entonces sabemos
que la matriz es invertible podemos
encontrar su inversa
ahora que hay de esta otra matriz la
matriz 1020 250 500 es esta matriz
invertible
bueno el determinante de 10 20 250 y 500
serán 10 por 500 lo cual es 5.000 menos
20 por 250 lo cual también es 5000 por
lo tanto el determinante cero una vez
más si queremos encontrar su inversa
entonces calcularemos la matriz adjunta
y la multiplicaremos por uno entre el
determinante pero 1 entre 0 no está
definido por lo tanto esta matriz no es
invertible
espero que todo esto sea de ayuda nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo